So I’ve been studying some Japanese Death
poems as I finish up my short film, Dreadful
Misfortune.
I’ll talk more about that in the coming
months.
But with National Poetry Day coming up, I’m
doing this collab with Don’t Turn Around,
where we’ll be reading you some horror poetry.
I thought it would be fun to practice writing
some Japanese Death Poems and put a CZsWorld
twist on it, so I’m gonna base each of these
poems on some of my favorite horror anime,
and whoever can guess what they’re from
will win some kind of shoutout or something.
And stick around to the end where I’ll narrate
the Japanese Death Poem from my upcoming film,
Dreadful Misfortune.
Ichi
I opposed the move.
Gazing on empty caskets.
He inquired aloud.
Aren’t you afraid of dying?
I’ve been dead for some time now.
Ni
Monsters roam this world.
But justice will come swiftly,
as with all monsters.
I know this monster because,
in truth, I am that monster.
San
The ninth grade, class three.
Would be the last grade, for me.
As with those before.
A curse to grea t to ignore.
Ignore her, to live one more.
Shi
Twelve contestants play.
A twisted and fatal game.
When even peers lock.
Even friendship goes to shame.
She only has her, to blame.
Go
The coffee’s a bit strong.
And this date’s gone on too long.
City lights so dim.
Walk me home, they look so grim.
Leaving half of me with him.
Bonasu
The ink of this scribe,
is only seen in the eyes,
of shinigami,
who possess glowing white eyes.
Dreadful misfortune, runs dry.
The voice you heard in this video was Don’t
Turn Around.
Click the link right here to listen to the
epic horror poem that I helped narrate on
their channel.
Remember to subscribe to CZsWorld for new
horrors every week, ring that deathbell for
notifications and I’ll see you in the next
one.
Assuming, we both survive.